I was in London when I was 19 and of
course it was raining the whole time but
my brother and I got up early we were
like so jazz that we were in dude
London really has to figure out Europe
or a nut Europe but like I guess Great
Britain needs to figure out its [ __ ]
breakfast situation man when I was in
London my brother I got up early cuz we
were like jet lag we're like let's go
explore one till ghosts were like let's
get some breakfast dude and we went and
first of all every place I would look a
bit like oh that's not a breakfast place
but that's not a breakfast place that's
not we finally settled on one that you
were at the counter and look like a
[ __ ] breakfast place so we looked up
and we were trying to get breakfast and
they were like what do you have for
breakfast and they just pointed and the
only thing that they were serving I
swear to God my brother and I we ate for
real this was the breakfast beans and a
tomato
hey people in London that's not
breakfast
that's not even lunch or dinner that's
like the [ __ ] that you put on stuff to
eat full breakfast full English mm-hmm
uh Great Britain and Ireland English
breakfast in the full English breakfast
often consists of bacon fried egg
sausage mushrooms baked bean toast
what the [ __ ] up with beans bro that
seems like a weird breakfast thing you
should have that for lunch or dinner
cause he'll be farting all day
uh-uh I'll sit going
excuse me about that and a crank being a
London breakfast so sorry
you know how it is here it's 11:30 and I
just digested my beans and sausage carry
on as he walks away hello excuse me I
just ate you guessed it beans and a
tomato excuse me where's the bathroom
it doesn't matter at this point I [ __ ]
my pants excuse me we've really got to
figure out this breakfast situation also
just so you know bacon to us
it's pretty much just not cooked all
right just cut off the side of a pig and
put it in my mouth
excuse me I hate beans and the raw side
of a pig
carrion just ate a tomato excuse me do
you know which way the bathroom
never mind I [ __ ] my pants carry on
worst worst you know when direct Jake
does that sign and it starts with worst
that's what he's talking about somebody
said hey Dre before you start recording
what's the worst [ __ ] how what do you
think your English breakfast and he goes
worse and then they started the song
that's what happened they go Drake well
you think of London breakfast all right
videos you know hey Drake what we think
in London breakfast
worse
so not worth it for the joke Jesus
Christ took so long you know I don't
give a [ __ ] this how he do it Nicky
Drake what'd you think of the breakfast
in London worse that's it what happened
to Chamillionaire bro that guy ripped
dude Chamillionaire okay I'm like a big
bun B fan and [ __ ] like that I love
rappers from the South I love what's his
name slim thug but Chamillionaire that
guy when he came out on the [ __ ]
scene I was like that's a rap dude my
favorite rapper is southern and then he
just like quit and bought an app or some
[ __ ]
he's like a tech guy now bro commit
first of all his name is Chamillionaire
that's hilarious dude that song in the
trunk was the [ __ ] illest rap song in
a long time in the trunk Chamillionaire
dude it's so funny
he's so [ __ ] make another song bro he
doesn't give a [ __ ] I think he's sitting
pretty I texted bumpy I'm from I'm
buddies with problem being bumpy we text
each other and [ __ ] I was like what
having a Chamillionaire and there's like
yeah it doesn't really rap anymore now
it's like man and that's pretty much it
hello do you know which wipe never mind
carry on pardon me I a tomato and some
beans on the side of a pig should make
that in back to work
ah man I'm just I don't know should we
do some mitts Connect connections or
what oh wow
chamillionaire's real name is Hakeem sir
iki Wow damn how old is he 39 he's my
age bro Wow I realized my buddy was
always talking about my buddies like 53
it's not bryan callen but he was like
and he was like hey man he's like I look
good for my age a lot of people of 53
they look [ __ ] terrible and I was
like you look 53 like in my head I was
like no you don't you look 53 straight
up and then I always felt that way about
myself like I don't look 39 but I
[ __ ] so I was like oh dude that's
just something people do in their brains
to make it okay I'm like I [ __ ] for
sure look 39 and that's it and that's
fine and I'm gonna just accept that dude
because when I see other 39 year olds I
think oh I don't look at that but I do
I'm mama [ __ ] 39 and I look that way
you look your age whether you think it
or not you know I mean unless you're
like Justin Timberlake but even I saw a
picture of Justin Timberlake the other
day and he looked old as [ __ ] so even
just a gentleman like falls into falls
victim to it